as it's strome Carlson of a Tonto and Carlson
steals it Center and brings it into the St
Louis Zone peels off of Justin faul and feeds the
point fower shot got through off the pad of huler
in front it was vrono and I think Frank may have
gotten a piece of that silverbird couldn't get it
out because Ley activated big Kevin Hayes across
the top of the zone to lety his shot got through
Gibson left a little rebound laying around
and he had to deal with it as cin got to it
and took a chop at it ducks have been hemmed
In Their Own Zone a couple of times already
in the early going they keep it on the perimeter
here as the blues go for changes Fowler restarts
and his pass through the middle tipped ahead
Carlson goes and gets it lays it off to stro
who keeps it moving below the goal line Carlson
sends it around right Point leushin PS it to the
net long rebound just out of the reach Carlson
pokes it back though and then kov gets it on net
a good save by hord McTavish gloves it down
as he got it from color trailing the play as
Bo grw now in front in the slot it's color big
save Joel hord in hand into John Gibson the play
continued at the opposite end Bo what a great
chance for Alex color don't think he was able
to quite Elevate that puck as high Henri from a
bad angle couldn't get it through as perunovic
stepped out to block it and the blues break out
the other way Kyu hands it off which he's got
room he fires off the glove of Gibson BR sends it
rink wide Shen trying to get it through bakan and
that was unsuccessful and here comes Carlson
again across the line with vrono vrono pulls
up waiting for a trailer throws it off the corner
for so and bakan it back to out M A score Carlson
I believe will get the goal but it was bakan who
kept the Play Alive into the goal crease Anaheim
has a one- nothing lead but he sent that he was
just flying down the wing watch what vrono does
I mean he purposely Banks this into the corner
vodan gets to the front of the net that might
be vodan Nan's goal I mean it goes off his
stick and then I think it goes off of Fulk
before it goes into the back of the net oh my
the blues are challenging that this was offside
or vadine I he did everything right see this
is what great Cronin is looking for have that
[Music] defense if it weren't for bad luck he
wouldn't have any it's really showing up in
his play I think he's been terrific this season
missed over 50 games twice in his career last
season bakan was out for the last 32 games with
that hip injury 59 and all and it's fair to say
I don't know that the Ducks were counting on a lot
from OV vaka based on the last couple of season I
I think the Dale injury Jake neighbors drags it
along the kick plate only to have it stolen out
of his feet by leushin Ilia lbushkin entering
tonight now fourth in the league in Block shots
here's a turnover and a chance that the blues
put in the back of the net it's Jake neighbors
his second goal in his many games the turnovers
have just killed the Ducks this season haven't
they he tries to pop it into the middle and it's
intercepted and then a quick little onetime or
one pass I think that shot actually hits the
Stick of Ilia lbushkin and changes Direction
makes it impossible for John Gibson yeah it
does HS the shaft of the stick and goes in
and shoulders were slumped he did everything
right tried to get into the shooting Lane and
unfortunately didn't work out for him fourth of
the year for neighbors and here comes toropchenko
he hit Gibson up high with that Rolling Puck
but tono trying to get the handle on reaches
to get it across the line his pass broken up to
Carlson gets a second bit Carlson from below the
goal line trying to sneak it through Hofer who
hangs on you know this is an intentional little
chip stro steps in to take the draw Carlson
marches to the corner after it and stro cuts
it off behind the net into the slot patronal good
save Hofer and he reels The Rebound in another
Faceoff win for the Ducks color hands it off to
lbushkin he was all tangled up in neighbors and
now McTavish brings it to the slot followed up
color Let It Go and it's gobbled up they're on
top one nothing with 339 to play and a Face-Off
win to begin the man Advantage Robert Thomas
stepped into along the boards as perunovich digs
it Loose across for kyou kyou back hand pass pass
to the far post and they score the Blues win a
board battle and B nvit with the Finish makes
it two nothing yeah and credit Jordan kyou who
gets this Puck here's the board battle was Sam
Carrick Fowler goes over he's thinking about
helping out but when the puck moves down low
cam can't get back to that far post ravish is wide
open Jordan kyou makes a play I mean that's a ter
teric backhand pass through the triangle a very
successful opening shift to the period for the
blues and they again do not give the easy out to
Anaheim Robert Thomas I me there's a reason why
he and kyou got those big contracts he works
it down low for kyou and a big stop by Gibson
nice Peaches and Herb reference by you going with
reunited thank you here's a chance for the Ducks
color denied his first goal in black and orange
kicked ahead here's kaep and he's got plenty of
speed to burn gets it into the slot Hayes has
to receive it on the back hand hands it off
and coming late right down the slot firing It
Wide torup chenko Tory Krug with a shot that
Gibson never saw sailed wide off the boards Hayes
spinning it back in front and tchenko scores on a
spinorama find it before pav M mov can
hay is just going to spin around throw
it to the net it's somebody in the foot
and just like that I mean Gibson wasn't
able to track it it came was right between
the feet 14th NHL season undrafted out of
Michigan State in the offseason the blues
had a deal to move him here's Mavis and
he Roots the backhander the ducks with some
life and Mavis with his eighth of the year
Mason Mavish is able to exploit it there's
the for check there's the turnover that puck
is tapped right back out in front by color
boy alex color kind of hung in there one
hand on the stick kind of little sweep check
knocked it towards Mason McTavish and a nice
finish by Mason watch this moves the puck a
long distance to the backhand side and even
with that curb stick perunovich gives it up
and gets it back on the right side works the
half wall Ducks pack it inside they get it Down
Low cross ice pass what a save by Gibson and now
the Ducks will go shorthanded right there but man
that's call Great Stop moments ago by John Gibson
on ver boy Energizer punny Frank patrono H into
the middle of the ice po navit marches down the
slot is backhander grabbed off by Gibson in the
neutral zone and way to the races bavis he's been
good in this game they stretch it long up the
left side color does well to collect it bring
it into the zone drop P Jones that got the goal
post they were this close to making it a one goal
[Applause] [Music] game he gets it back spinning
it into the middle and McTavish fumbled it away
at the Blue Line thrown out by Falon off the
boards tchenko has Hayes with him brings it in
a glove save from John Gibson and as a result you
know you just don't win in this league if you can
only get one goal scored John Gibson I thought was
very good in this game but as has been the story
for Gibson this season he's not getting much
in the way or run support certainly not lately